my character is the comic relief in the
game sir Cadwell he's a kind of Don
Quixote character
he's loves battle he loves to go on a
quest and to try and help helpless
maidens and all that kind of thing and
he loves fighting but he never seems to
be the slightest bit scared about me
regards it as a great game and if he is
wounded then he's incredibly brave about
it and the British sort of work this is
the second was no no no this is pretty
much the worst thing one fine day in the
middle of the night two dead Kings
got up to fight back to back they faced
each other through their bows and
stabbed themselves I have the artist
feeling we've discussed this before I
already mentioned it I am sir CAD well
the undaunted Knights of the court of
Coldharbour champion of chivalry
defender of the defenseless Shepherd to
the soul shriven well this has my
knickers in a twist we have a perfectly
fine army but what good is it sitting
around this side of the chasm twiddling
its collective thumbs it's rather
embarrassing if truth be told I always
thought it would be wonderful to be a
great Archer I think I grew up on Robin
Hood and westerns we're sort of people
fired guns or arrows very very
accurately and that always appealed to
me and but if you wanted to be a bowmen
in the in the British Army in 1350 for
example in the Battle of Crecy you had
to start very very young because you had
to develop the most extraordinary
musculature I like it when my character
Sir Cadwell gets rather vague or
confused or like it when he says if you
know us tell me about yourself Carroll
he says I have the oddest Feeny we
discussed this before or did I already
mention it hmm so no matter I like that
kind of vagueness I like playing them
based on my experience with the elders
girls online I would definitely do
another video game because I had a
really good laugh that was really fun
and I'm interested to see not that I'm
very good at playing video games I feel
like I would only sort of get to the
first level and never see this stuff
I've done but it was it was really fun
but definitely do him I like being in
the dark
I'd voice queen I ran in this and she is
Queen so she's quite tough and
uncompromising but then seems to have
you know soft aside in a humorous side
and I've enjoyed all of that stuff but I
did quite like when I had to talk to
somebody who turned into a cat but I was
a man I've been a man as her twice and
and that was quite fun I wasn't
expecting to have to do that
outright traitors like norian we end no
question the problem is that traitors
like norian are only Fanning the flame
if I can't win over my people the
heritance will be dealing with me
instead of the other way around your
King needs to stop talking out of the
side of his mouth he has a lot of
Dominion blood on his hands
we're not going to easily forget that
and we're certainly not going to fight
by his side in Cold Harbor I think they
will find my character is very fair and
a very good leader very imposing and a
great warrior but also has a kind of
softer side and and a very good heart
and will be helpful to the player I
think my character is a very imposing
leader and a great female strong role
model but she's also somebody who has a
lot of hardship and tragedy and betrayal
going on during the video game and and I
think that gives her quite a sort of
sympathetic side that I think people
will respond to
videogames have got better they're much
better now like the Elder Scrolls is the
best friend going I think mine is the
best part because but I hope you all
love it I'm sure you will
I'll take aware that love and I
understanding and caring I hope they
take it out with the character I play is
blind and so so I put my glasses on and
I act blind if you don't worry carefully
we'll see my eyes are closed which is
very clever for me to do that and then I
stick them open that again till it's
tired of it to read the lines the Elder
Scrolls online marks the second video
game things like that I have to read
them out loud so how on earth they
expect me to pay a blind man and also
speak a lot leaves me you know angry I
get very angry about it by Liris are you
alright
there is are you all right nothing like
that
hit it good right indeed but let us not
get ahead of ourselves without an
understanding of where we are bound the
Red Guards sword master sighs aha the
leader of the Imperial dragon guard
and truth I heard you'd kill me where I
stood if you knew who I was
you certainly wouldn't have allied with
us sir Italy I caused this all of this
if Molag Bal destroys this world the
blame will be mine and mine alone
well I'd like to pay an elf that's the
part I'd be really good at elves are
quite short I'm not sure I'm a bit
overweight and not very tall but an elf
would appeal to me they're funny they're
interesting they climb trees so an elf
would be my sort of thing I'd be an elf
also yet they have the added advantage
elves of sitting down without my love
sitting down if you play the king or
some Juke or something have to keep
walking around I don't know so I'd be
happy to play an elf
I like the elderscrolls I'm tailor-made
for the part and I'm used to playing
blind men which I always play blind men
I enjoy it very much
the character that I play in the elder
scrolls is called a beneath on the best
way of describing would be supremely
confident and arrogant a man who clearly
has a very very high opinion of himself
and a very low opinion of others which
is even more crucial
there's this ongoing sense of him being
very sarcastic and very aloof he he
doesn't quite believe that anyone can be
as powerful or as strong or as decisive
as he is or as they need to be so
there's always this little tension of
trying to you know he's very sparing
with his compliments but very generous
with his with his sarcasm I know more
about the danger than any man alive for
good or ill my family has always kept
ties with the forces of oblivion and
this much I know one can't kill a
dangerous Prince but we have the amulet
of Kings so where to stumble blindly
into the catacombs beneath a crumbling
ruin now abandoned for an age
lovely but being an idiot sword master
will lead us straight in joy trap no
doubt it's my small-minded nephew Joe
bird the lad was petting and cruel for
the enjoyment of it I always suspected
he'd meet an untimely end leave him to
his fate it's kinder than he deserves
and then what I have no idea what will
happen to you apotheosis disintegration
too many unknowns and not enough
information but if you defeat molag bal
and survive your soul and the soul of
every other surviving vestige should be
restored the amulet of Kings is a relic
of akatosh the dragon god of time his
powers embody the qualities of
perseverance and invincibility while
promoting the virtues of duty service
and obedience make of that what you will
one of the big elements in the character
is that he's he's he's very very
beautiful very pompous and very arrogant
but he's actually very funny and he is
his his sarcasm and his kind of sort of
dismissal of other people can be really
I mean there's one line where he's
talking to Liris and he says something
like you know in a very kind of
understanding and supportive and
sympathetic way he says you know
something like I understand this must be
very hard for your liras but don't be an
idiot
it's my right and it's just that I mean
I'm paraphrasing so I can't remember the
line now but it's it was the it was the
turn of phrase they say cuz it started
off so kind of like like a he was just
about to give her a hug and they turns
into this kind of like wonderful slap
and slap in the face and then it was
that that that way of just turning
within a lion turning everything around
like that was very indicative of him but
that line in particulars you know it
must be very as hard as it might be for
you Lewis don't be an idiot
it kind of made me laugh
the character I play in the Elder
Scrolls online is king Emmerich and he's
a good guy
generally speaking what's cool about him
is that he's not uncomplicated sin to
all kinds of moods but he's generally in
the in the context within the context of
the Elder Scrolls online he is a good
force but in the world he has some funny
lines
he's not just some King guy he also is a
human being and he has some he has some
funky asides to make and he is he is the
king of all ribbon spire and he's a
pretty cool guy in my view I'm not just
defending my character I actually
believe that he's very very he's a
serious hands-on King he doesn't hang
around in throne rooms telling other
people how to fight battles he's out
there he's on horseback he's getting
bloody he doesn't fool around and he's
never lost a battle as far as I know
which just right there is pretty cool I
will not wager the future of my people
on the word of a snow barbarian and an
adolescent female I fear that Tamriel
future if either of you were to sit upon
the Ruby throne this crown one day I
will throw this crown in a lake this
Kremlin was probably great for my
grandfather
this crown looks tawdry why can't they
shine it up now again everyone's so
scared to touch the ground I could at
least clean it this crown makes me look
stupid sits on my ears my ears and on my
picture probably tighten this crown
slightly I'm blinded by it if I'm riding
on a horse
this crowd is an embarrassment to the
kingdom he has many many wonderful lines
I like his epithets perhaps best I like
I loved saying you know don't go easy on
me it's you know I'm being honest I got
a kick out of saying on Mara's bosom I
like it when things get daft it means
you're not being a nuisance in the world
means you're doing something actually in
a kind of you know funky way that's
useful and you're not you know invading
Iraq so I'm hoping they come to me with
a warm feeling and I hope that by the
time they leave they feel a whole lot
better
I say encouraging stuff I point them in
the right direction I don't sell them
any nonsense and I'm generally on the
players side and it's also part of my
job I have to say that if they do
anything wrong in the game I get to tell
them but then that's it stop being a
king and and the crown doesn't fit
because my great-great-great
great-great-grandfather apparently must
have had a very small head so I get a
lot of crown aches I like the variety of
things you have to achieve bocalee I
like the fact that it's concentrated
into a relatively short period of time
I've had a very pleasant time working
with the people here I'm in Paris I have
to come clean and it's it's a beautiful
summer's day
the character that I'm playing in the
Elder Scrolls or as we like to say the
scrolls those of that as a part of the
family you know
well of course I am playing an
arch-villain and but as I always say you
know a piece is only as good often as
its filler and I think this one is
particularly nasty actually and I think
he's gonna beat up the player of the
game quite nicely and and by the way
he's not really very polite which I do
like about him I'm from the north of
England where rather gruff in the north
of England and I like that no-nonsense
right to it but does he have a heart of
course he does so we try and give him
some some vulnerability I don't quite
know what it is but and do I enjoy
playing them of course I do
I mean I'd much rather play the heavy
than the hero submit to the will of
Milan bar fall to your knees and worship
I don't need to kill you I just need you
to wish you were dead I grow weary of
your games nvidia i am god of oblivion
you are less than nothing
I will have you vestige pathetic
prophecies and trinkets of holy powers
are fleeting I am immortal
I am undying your world will drown in
blood all shall be mine I would hope
that the people will go wow
that guy was pretty cool I don't want
them to emulate what he's doing or
saying even but just you know he's got
to be this threat and and you know I
hope there's a little bit of humor there
somewhere he's one of those characters
really a beloved and sweet guy
underneath all that your black heart
pleases me mortal I'll leave one day you
yes well the character that I'm playing
in the Elder Scrolls there's no lag ball
or little Moe for short he's actually
how can I put this
he's a I hate to use this word but it's
the only word really describes him a
demon God I think that actually video
games they lend themselves beautifully
for movies don't a lot of them about I'm
Malcolm McDowell and we've been working
on the elder scrolls and I'm playing the
part of little no he's an evil bastard
you